quería preguntarle Más allá del aumento
de las temperaturas que otros fenómenos
puede causar el niño y hasta cuándo
puede durar
bueno Rodrigo pues Espera que haya un
90% de probabilidades que este fenómeno
se extienda hasta el segundo semestre
y esto afecta particularmente América
del Sur con lluvias extremas en la parte
meridional y también con sequías en la
parte norte este fenómeno probablemente
vamos a aumentar la temperatura más
arriba de uno punto cinco grados de
manera temporal que es la meta que los
científicos nos han dicho que no debemos
rebasar y que los países del mundo se
comprometieron a no rebasar en el
acuerdo de París Esta es una alerta de
que no vamos por el mejor camino Rodrigo
quería preguntarle precisamente que
tiene de especial el episodio de este
año y cómo le afecta el cambio climático
algo que quizás ya nos ha ido
adelantando
Bueno pues veamos en la historia 2016 ha
sido el año más caluroso de toda la
historia porque se conjuntaron este
fenómeno del niño y también el
calentamiento provocado por las
actividades humanas ahora con este
fenómeno el niño y el calentamiento
global que no hemos detenido porque
seguimos consumiendo combustibles
fósiles se espera que los siguientes
cinco años sea el más caluroso el
quinquenio 2023
sea el más caluroso de toda la historia
como decía esto provoca lluvias extremas
sequías Huracanes inundaciones es
importante que tomemos esta alerta que
que reviremos nuestra nuestro modo de
combustibles fósiles que vayamos hacia
hacia energía renovables movilidad
eléctrica y compartida eh Y también
conservar nuestros ecosistemas Rodrigo
se espera que el que el impacto de este
fenómeno se vea más en 2024 y este año
vimos en muchos lugares del mundo que el
calor era inaguantable y en la región de
América Latina qué se podría hacer en
materia ambiental para paliar quizás las
consecuencias de episodios como este
vemos Que países como Colombia o Brasil
están intentando revertir esa Tala
masiva de árboles de la amazonía pero
más allá que se puede hacer
Bueno pues primero hay que mejorar los
sistemas de alertas temprana para salvar
vidas y también los medios de
subsistencia en no estar agricultura de
nuevo hay que cambiar a medios de
producción de energía renovable tenemos
que mejorar nuestra ciudad de Rodrigo
Ahí es donde se produce la mayor
cantidad de gases de efecto invernadero
tenemos que proteger nuestros
ecosistemas las selvas los océanos hay
suficiente capital en el mundo para
hacer frente a esta problemática y ahora
lo que tenemos que hacer es invertir el
dinero público el dinero privado y el
dinero internacional hacia la mitigación
y la adaptación al cambio climático
También en esta región países como
Ecuador y Perú se ven afectados por un
fenómeno Paralelo que es el denominado
como niño costero nos podría dar algún
dato concreto de Qué es este otro
fenómeno
bueno Perú en el en el último periodo
que vimos este fenómeno del 97 al 98
perdió casi el 5% del pib porque las
inundaciones fueron tan extremas que se
perdió la infraestructura y se prevé que
este año al menos sea moderado el
fenómeno y podemos ver también serias
afectaciones a la infraestructura y a
las vidas de las personas de nuevo que
tengamos buenos sistemas de alerta
temprana va a ser muy importante que la
población está enterada de qué es lo que
se viene que nosotros sistemas
agroecológicos estén bien preparados
porque también otra otro fenómeno que
vimos después de este periodo fueron las
migraciones forzadas Rodrigo desde
Sudamérica y América del centro hacia
América del Norte generando también
problemas sociopolíticos y xenofóbicos
en Estados Unidos